this year susan sarandon is nominated
for her performance in a powerful movie
about capital punishment and forgiveness
called dead man walking
please welcome another wonderful actress
who's played a nun Susan Sarandon
the sport of writing a successful
original screenplay takes the patience
of chess the endurance of rock-climbing
and dexterity of gymnastics all combined
with the loneliness of the long distance
runner the nominees in the race for best
screenplay written directly for the
screen are Randall Wallace for
Braveheart Woody Allen for mighty
Aphrodite
Steven J Revell Christopher Wilkinson
and Oliver Stone for Nixon Joss Whedon
Andrew Stanton Joel Coen and Alec
Sokolow screenplay and John Lasseter
Peter dr. Andrew Stanton and Joe grant
story for tours story
christopher mcquarrie for the usual
suspects
and the Oscar her breasts original
screenplay
goes to Christopher McQuarrie for the
usual suspects
45 seconds oh boy
I share this award with Kenneth Koken
John Atman and Bryan Singer the three
greatest collaborators and friends one
could ever hope to have
I want to thank Cheryl show fie my love
and my inspiration dylan cuspid the
initial spark Deanna Hensley the first
believer my entire family who was
convinced and my mother who was always
certain and to my father who offered me
some words of wisdom as the film was
going into production
he said enjoy this time this is the
moment the candy store is never so good
as when you're looking in well dad I'm
in the candy store
put er there kid it's great